gros bongo bisous à tous mais mon match
j'ai une surprise de ouf pour toi c'est
vrai alors j'en ai une première et une
deuxième lame et regarde y'a une amie
j'ai une très grande amie dans le
showbiz quelqu'un avec qui on est comme
ça je vous cache pas que non il ya eu le
dire n'a pas eu de balle du tout vous
êtes la came c'est de l'amitié
oui mais non c'est de l'amitié arrêt qui
n'est pas là dedans on l'a oublié nature
des cendres de 0,2 de boules est là
alors s'agit d'une star internationale à
blanc que tu connais aussi son prénom
ses ébats aux noms sont annoncés soit
mendes et longoria et oui mais les rats
longoria avait chanté pour elle une fois
une ou deux trois fois où je sais rien
c'est d'ailleurs dans un thé tube cool
parce que j'utilise tes paroles si
j'aimerais beaucoup que méchante elle a
donc fait à longueur cesse à capter et
bats toi te regarder une photo
d'ailleurs la chanson j'adore ça mais ça
c'est pas classe à manger une photo avec
isabelle du mal de ma classe de 5e est
donc vous lui avez chanté une sérénade
et vous aviez aussi chanté pour elle sur
votre tube bella regarder et après on
amitié surprise pour vous
[Musique]
et bien qu'elle j j'appelais bascons
bieber j'ai appelé eva longoria
alors ils sont numéro numéro d'eva
longoria il adrian bien eva yamaha a
envoyé un petit message pourquoi
consentir à sydney elle est là on la
replace en belgique
gros bisous à tous mes matches il faut
un gros bisou alors là j'ai une surprise
pour vous sachez qu'il ya sur twitter on
va donner le hashtag tout de suite
maniez bull qui tout est expliqué sur
twitter vous allez sur le cd tu vous
allez sur le poulet est arrêtée tout
comme hier en mairie jusqu'au massacre
sur le compte twitter de tpm paix vous
d'y aller et il y à un dîner en
compagnie en présente les vallons gorga
le 18 mai au à cannes et j'y serai
également à nom auquel nous et non vers
vous j'y serai également merci alors
franchement à l'aise y inscrire ou sur
twitter et il y aura un tirage au sort
je pense que kenji sera avec moi
j'espère bien entendu puisque tu sais
qu'à partir d'aujourd'hui on ne se
lâchent plus cadjee est ce que tu peux
nous faire franchement parce que c'est
une de mes chansons préférées en plus
aux commerciaux c'est je vais mettre en
position position
eiffage essorage on y va tous ensemble
et aux attentes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]